le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais
dans notre société être différent peut
rendre la vie au quotidien plus
difficile pourtant être différent ne
veut pas forcément dire incompétent
trouver du travail quand on n'est pas
tout à fait comme tout le monde et
souvent très compliqué les préjugés
mettent beaucoup de barrières les
employeurs ne réagissent pas forcément
bien face à des personnes porteuses de
handicap malgré les obligations légales
alors quels sont les alternatives à ce
problème on en parle maintenant dans
lien social
c'est à Saint-Denis dans le parc auto du
conseil général qu'Olivier travaille
depuis maintenant plus d'un an ce jeune
homme dynamique a été embauché pour ses
compétences et c'est facilités en
informatique diplômés en transport
logistique Olivier a subi quelques
échecs pendant des entretiens d'embauche
avant d'être retenu au conseil général
ces précédents échecs ne sont pas dues à
ces compétences mais à son handicap
carolivier est considéré autiste de
niveau 1 est présente quelques
difficultés à gérer son stress dans des
moments importants
dans le monde du travail mais j'ai quand
même effectué quelques stages dans mon
cadre du BTS donc je connaissais le
monde du travail dans le en tant que
stage mais mon vrai mon premier emploi
c'est ici et bah j'ai subi quelques
échecs dans mes recherches d'emploi j'ai
postulé dans plusieurs entreprises de
transport et de logistique et voilà et
donc les entretiens se sont pas
forcément très bien passés parce que
quand je passe en entretien j'ai
tendance à focaliser sur ce que je dois
dire pas dire de bêtises et en fait ça
fait l'effet inverse c'est-à-dire au
lieu d'être naturel et détendu je suis
stressé au parc auto du conseil général
je me sens intégrée déjà depuis le
depuis le jour de mon entretien
d'embauche le patron m'a mis dans de
bonnes conditions il m'a fait comprendre
il y avait une bonne ambiance que les
collègues étaient accueillants et tout
ça et j'ai pu moi-même constater qu'il y
avait une bonne ambiance et donc avec
mes collègues qui sont dans mon bureau
ça se passe super bien et les autres
collègues aussi et donc voilà je suis
content de travailler dans
moi c'est une forme légère d'autisme
donc au premier abord ça se voit pas
mais voilà j'ai plus de mal justement
dans les relations dans le stress et
tout ça donc je sais que
dans les il y a plusieurs choses que
j'ai dû à faire donc passer le permis de
conduire qui m'ont pris plus de temps
que quelqu'un de je dirais normal mais
quelqu'un quelqu'un classique qui
prendra beaucoup moins de temps que moi
j'ai pris mais il y a plein de trucs que
je fais et qui sont une fois que j'ai
réfléchi ben je trouve que c'est en
dépit du bon sens mais je le fais comme
ça naturellement mais si je vais dans un
environnement inconnu c'est là j'avais
si par exemple je devais
aller dans avoir un grand directeur pour
une réunion particulière si c'est une
personne que j'ai jamais vu où il y a un
enjeu bah là je stress voilà quand on
m'a demandé de prendre la parole devant
la présidente entre autres et la
dernière fois pour parler de mon
expérience j'étais stressée au début
j'étais pas stressée mais quand j'ai dû
prendre la parole bah là voilà faire un
peu de moyens parce que il y avait tout
tous les directeurs qui étaient là et
tout ça donc c'était un peu important
comme Olivier beaucoup de personnes
porteuses du handicap ont des
compétences qui méritent d'être
valorisées et qui sont nécessaires dans
le milieu professionnel
malheureusement le monde du travail ne
voit pas les choses de la même façon
certains employeurs sont réticents à
l'embauche de ces personnes pour des
raisons assez vagues le Conseil général
a fait de l'intégration de personnes
porteuses de handicap une de ses
priorités avec pour objectif d'atteindre
le seuil de 6% des effectifs d'ici 2015
nous avons commencé à aider les
personnes porteuses de handicap sur des
aides financières matériels le transport
mais pour qu'il rentre dans le milieu
ordinaire quel est le meilleur la
meilleure façon c'est qu'il soit dans
les milieux professionnels que on puisse
les accompagner aussi sur un
épanouissement et tout le monde sait que
son travail on a du mal et donc c'est
vrai que aujourd'hui nous recrutons des
personnes porteuses handicap au sein
même du conseil général parce qu'ils
seront eux aussi des vecteurs justement
de l'épanouissement et de
l'accompagnement que nous mettons en
place en milieu ordinaire pour toutes
les personnes handicap elles sont
aujourd'hui diplômées elles ont des
savoir-faire et elles ont des
compétences
personne porteuse de handicap sont au
cœur des priorités du département
nombreux sont les dispositifs qui leur
permettent d'exercer leur citoyenneté
montrer l'exemple en les intégrant dans
le milieu du travail s'inscrit dans
cette même logique pour que chacun
puisse se sentir fier d'être réunionnais
le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous a
présenté lien social le Conseil général
aux côtés des Réunionnais